Speaker 1: We have to absolutely huge stories
to start with today, and I wasn't sure which
to start with, but let's just start with the
first one.
We have now learned that Apple has given the
Trump or gave at the time the Trump administration
information and documents on Democratic lawmakers.
And this is yet another attempted or real
abuse of subpoena power to obtain documents
about the political enemies of the Trump administration.
And we also, of course, have to consider the
role which Apple itself has played.
Let's take a look at an article from Thomson
Reuters which says Apple on Friday said it
has tightened some of its rules for responding
to legal requests after the U.S. Justice Department
during Donald Trump's presidency subpoenaed
it for information on Democratic lawmakers.
Apple said it recently instituted a limit
of twenty five identifiers, such as email
addresses or phone numbers per legal request.
So so far, what they're saying is, if you're
going to do this, you'll have to make multiple
requests.
You can't give us a list of one hundred identifiers.
You'll have to give us four for lists of twenty
five.
The Cupertino, California based company said
it received a subpoena from the Justice Department
in February.
Twenty eighteen for information on one hundred
and nine identifiers made up of 73 phone numbers
and 36 email addresses, but that it did not
release content such as emails and pictures
to prosecutors, The New York Times on Thursday
reported.
And we will get to that report that federal
prosecutors subpoenaed Apple and other companies
as part of an investigation, searching for
the sources behind media news reports about
contacts between Trump's associates and Russia.
This is a key line.
What was the point of this?
What was it that the Trump administration
at the Trump Justice Department was seeking
to find out in requesting this information?
They were trying to uncover the sources, the
journalistic sources for reporting about Trump
administration contacts with Russia.
Think back to when this was going on.
And there were reports about Jeff Sessions
said there were no contacts.
But look at all these contacts that we found.
Donald Trump said there were no contacts,
the whole list of these people.
So the Trump administration through the Justice
Department said, hey, you know what, let's
start figuring out let's get information from
people's iPhones and from the iCloud, from
the iCloud, whatever else was being used right.
Related to Apple or possibly being used.
Let's see if we can figure out who the sources
are or were for what these reports are claiming.
Trump publicly saying, oh, anonymous sources,
no, no, no, they're just bogus.
But privately, they knew they weren't bogus,
so much so that they were trying to figure
out exactly who they were publicly saying.
When you read anonymous source doesn't exist,
there's no one there's no real source privately
understanding there are sources and trying
to figure out exactly who those people are.
The investigation targeted, at least to Democrats
on the House of Representatives Intelligence
Committee aides and family members, including
one minor, The New York Times reported.
Apple said it had no way to tell what the
nature of the investigation was and released
only basic account subscriber information
such as names, addresses, email addresses,
phone numbers as well as connection logs and
IP addresses.
Apple said it did not provide data showing
to whom or when messages of any kind were
sent.
The New York Times then reporting the Justice
Department subpoenaed Apple for information
in February twenty eighteen about an account
that belonged to Donald F. McGann, the second
president, Donald Trump's White House counsel
at the time.
This is another wrinkle to this story.
This is another aspect which will we're still
trying to figure out for the most part, it
seems what was going on here was an attempt
to figure out who were the sources for the
news media, presumably on the Democratic side,
about these different contacts that the Trump
campaign and administration had with Russians.
But at the same time, the New York Times report
points out that there was an attempt to get
information about Donald Trump's lawyer as
well.
And The New York Times article says it was
not clear what FBI agents were investigating,
whether Mr. Morgan was there specific focus
or whether he was swept up in a larger net
because he had communicated with someone who
was under scrutiny.
That's another important aspect to understand.
There are some on the right saying this was
not a partizan thing being done by Trump loyalists
in the Justice Department looking for information
only.
On Democrats, as evidenced by the fact that
they were looking for information about Trump's
own lawyer, what it may have been, and if
it is, it's absolutely crazy that there was
some other person being scrutinized.
Imagine that there was just as a hypothetical,
some Russian national that was sort of at
the center of this.
The Justice Department may have been saying,
we need information on anybody who's been
in touch with this person.
And Apple may have seen a connection between
Meghann and that individual.
And so, incidentally, Meghann may have been
swept up on it.
We just don't know at this point in time is
the point.
Now, meanwhile, as reported by CNN's Manu
Raju, who tweeted over the weekend, quote,
Bar sessions and now Rosenstein say they were
unaware of the subpoenas sent under their
tenure for Democratic lawmakers records.
These are three people with a track record
of dishonesty, first of all.
So I wouldn't trust them much.
But what seems to be going on here is that
they are trying to get their stories straight
for one word answers if they're ever forced
to testify.
How nobody knew anything.
All of these subpoenas were filed, but nobody
knew who who authorized them, who signed.
We just don't know.
The administration was granted years long
gag orders against these subpoenas, same as
the others.
These were gag orders that were renewed multiple
times.
What judge okayed the renewal of the gag order
on the fact that these subpoenas were signed
off on and granted which judge or judges were
involved?
Do we need to subpoena the subpoenas to figure
out who is behind some of this stuff?
It is an incredible story.
It did not make the headlines, I might have
guessed it would have made or that that I
would have hoped it would make.
But a major story, which we are going to continue
following